over the past two decades motorcycle
world Lake Constance has become the
leading trade fair for motorbikes in
southern Germany Austria and Switzerland
it showcases all the latest products and
trends this year 807 bikes were on show
including 47 new models there were 20
different shows the three days in late
January were a taste of heaven for
bikers the classic journalist andreas
ilk says classic styles continued to be
in this year bikes with a retro look are
all the rage but customized and
reconfigured to fulfill the owners
wishes the BMW r90 is one such bike a
pure authentic design with plenty of
customizing options this Ducati
scrambler embodies the principle of less
is more the design is a mix of the
traditional and the modern the look is a
tribute to the wild 60s while the
technology is cutting-edge
Kawasaki may be renowned for its sporty
modern bikes but it's Vulcan s and
Vulcan vn900 also have a clearly retro
look
andreas points to technical advances
such as cornering abs which lets you
break hard even while leaning into a
bend without losing control that is a
huge advance another safety feature is
the gear shift assistant so far only BMW
has had it but this year other
manufacturers are set to introduce it it
lets you change gear with a simple kick
without using the clutch very practical
in rush-hour traffic this year the best
bike Awards sported the motto tuned and
pimped 24 distinctive customized bikes
were displayed they boasted all kinds of
special features this one is made of
wood and it even works
at the fair there was a special
exhibition on the history of the fabled
NSU brand put on in cooperation with a
German bicycle and NSU museum it showed
legendary motorbikes from the 1960s
including some great racing models
and then there were bikes that just make
you long for summer like this three
seater electoral tricycle byra waka it
is the first electrode trike to boast
100 kilowatts and a range of 120
kilometers
the slingshot by Polaris is a fun trike
for to its top speed is 220 kilometers
an hour and it takes just 5.6 seconds to
go from nought to 100 think how nice it
would be to take it out for a spin on a
warm summer's day
you